on October 29 this year, Ukraine committed a
terrorist act against
ships of the Black Sea Fleet and
civilian vessels involved in
ensuring the security of the grain
corridor. The Russian Federation
suspended the implementation of an agreement on the
export of agricultural products from
Ukrainian ports thanks to the participation
of the United Nations and also
assists Turkey in obtaining the
necessary written guarantees
from  Ukraine They use the
humanitarian corridor and Ukrainian
ports designated in the interests of exporting
agricultural products to
conduct hostilities against the
Russian Federation The Russian
Federation considers that the
guarantees received at the moment seem to
be sufficient and resumes the implementation of the
agreement.
Sevastopol
[applause]
[music]
their Putin
[applause]